je comprends le trouble que jette cette
information est d'ailleurs vous avez
appris comme moi qu'une enquête
judiciaire a été ouverte sur ce point
car s'il s'agissait bien d'une arme
opérationnel à l'évidence il n'avait pas
à la porté pendant la campagne
présidentielle
et si même il avait été autorisé à le
faire
cette forme d'exhibition est quelque
chose qui peut effectivement choquer le
public est choqué évidemment les
représentants de la nation que nous
sommes mais je tiens à vous dire que il
s'agit d'éléments qui font l'objet
maintenant d'une enquête judiciaire
je n'ai donc pas auditionner monsieur
benalla pour l'interroger sur son
comportement parce que je sortirai à ce
moment-là du mandat qui m'a été donné à
l'unanimité qui a été donné à la
commission des lois à l'unanimité par le
sénat le 23 juillet dernier pour
enquêter sur les conditions dans
lesquelles des personnes étrangères aux
forces de sécurité peuvent contribuer à
des opérations de sécurité et à la
protection de hautes personnalités
ça n'est pas le même sujet